كانت 100 يوم صعبه ما كنا نراه من مجازر
ومناظر مروعه وقتل للاطفال والابرياء كانت
يعني بالنسبه لاننا في الطوارئ معظم
الجرحى والاصابات اللي تيج والشهداء حتى
جوا الطوارئ اكثر من 70% منهم الاطفال
والنساء بنقدم ما نستطيع تقديمه حوالي جلس
22 يوم كاملات ما بعرفش اي حاجه عن اهلي
منمس فقط من ابناء عمومتي حوالي 70 شهيد
[موسيقى]
كانوا احنا افترضنا او توقعنا ان ممكن
تكون الحرب هذه لفتره بسيطه شهر شهر ونص
اما صراحه مدت كثير وصلت لعند ثلاث اشهر
تقريبا او اكثر من هيك فكل مالها قاعده
بتاخذ من اعمارنا وبتاخذ من صحتنا صراحه
[موسيقى]
يعني 100 يوم بعات الحرب اللي قضيناه وما
زلنا بنقضي برضه لانه الله يعلم و تخلص
الحرب بنرتاح احنا يا دوبنا في اليوم
الواحد بننام فييه ساعتين ثلاثه نتلقى
اشارات من الناس بيجوا المواطنين علينا
بييجوا باتصالات بييجوا الناس بيحكوا لنا
وجهونا على المكان كمان من ضمن المواقف
انه انا اهلي ابوي وامي واخويا شهداء انا
اللي رحت بحكم اسعاف في نفس الوقت انا
طلعت ابويا وامي واخويا طلعتهم من تحت
الانقاد مع تسعه اشخاص من
العيله في 100 يوم الحرب هي اصعب لحظه مرت
فيا يوم ما اضطريت انزح كنت راجعه للدوام
في مستشفى الشفاء وما قدرت اوصلها لانه
المستشفى كانت محاصره واضطريت امشي من
مستشفى الشفاء الى رفح كانت اصعب لحظه
وانا سايبه بقيه اصدقائي بقيه
مرضانا كانت اباده المستشفيات اباده
المراكز الصحيه بمعنى اباده يعني محو هذه
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه عن الارض كما
حصل في مستشفى الشفاء الطبي بان يعني
تخريب المواد
بهدم هدم من المباني الدخول الى مستشفى
المعمداني وقصفها واستشهاد اكثر ما يزيد
عن 500 شخص كذلك الدخول الى مستشفى النيسي
مستشفى كمال عدوان مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
التي قصفت بالامس كذلك مستشفى غزه
الاوروبي التي قصف كل محيط هواء مستشفانا
مستشفى الشهيد محمد يوسف النشر الذي قصفه
محيطه وتم تكسير كل يعني زجاج وشبابيك
المستشفى حتى الابواب بدات لا تغلق
المستشفيات اصبحت خارجه عن الخدمه التي هي
واقفه على دامها يعني مستشفى الشهيد محمد
يوسف النجار 63 سرير الان ينام بها 183
183 مريض والله لا اعلم كيف ينامون كيف
يقومون كيف يتم استخدام
الحمامات الشركات النظافه قد خرجت عن
الخدمه بعدم وجود الكلور عدم وجود مواد
التنظيف عدم وجود مواد
المعطره وقد قام بعض الاطباء يعني بتر
اقدام بعض الجرحى امام عينهم بتقدير موضعي
فقط لا يوجد تقدير كلي يعني برضه ايضا في
خلال ال 100 يوم احنا تعاملنا مع بعض
الحالات اللي بحتاجه الى تغريز ما كان في
اي بنج ما كان في اي تخدير يعني قليل جدا
جدا لتخدير الادويه المعدات الطبيه كان في
نقص وشحيح جدا يعني بقيت
لدرجه المصابين كنا نتعامل معهم على الارض
وليس فيش اسره تكفي لهم فعليا لعند درجه
اليوم اليوم انا هذا تعاملنا مع تقريبا
اربع خمس حالات على الارض من الاصابات
الصبح هذا هو حال
الطوار